hugh jackman here wish i could be there
with you trust me there is nothing more
I'd like to be doing than honoring and
celebrating the great Gene Kelly I am on
the set of lemons arrived we are making
a movie musical that's why of age 15
years as you can see uh-huh this is the
barricades behind us don't tell me I'm
on it sir
top top secret Gene Kelly honestly to me
as a hero as I remember growing up in
Australia in a suburb called Berenger in
the northern suburbs of Sydney getting a
VCR machine for the first time and my
father brought me a copy of singing in
the rain
I never seen or heard of him I watched
it 150 times I then watched everything
Gene Kelly had ever done he was to me
everything I would have ever dreamed
have been and then some an extraordinary
dancer his athleticism his grace his
choreography and ingenuity and his sense
of fun whilst he did it all his
inventiveness he critics creativity he's
singing his acting he's directing
everything just seemed to come from
within it seemed effortless even though
we all know of course it's not but it
seemed effortless and full of life and
joy he as a young kid he made me dream
of being in a movie musical and seven
years later at the age of 24 Here I am
in a movie musical gene and I can't
thank you enough for everything you've
done I know there's going to be many
many glowing tributes here tonight to
his family and friends who are there
celebrating I wish you all the best I
know you're going to have a terrific
night
Gene Kelly set the world on fire he was
about joy he was about celebrating life
so I'm thrilled thrilled thrilled to be
part of it thank you for having me
have a terrific night and next time I'm
on a wet road maybe I'll be singing that
dinner that art that our dad